foreign
[Applause]
don't lose
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
let's back
[Applause]
y'all ready for a good Governor
you're ready for a great president
[Applause]
Governor just got here he's been in he's
been in uh the low country
hold up
all right give me a minute
[Music]
is that better
all right
I'm nervous as a Cat on a Hot Tin Roof
so y'all
anyway I appreciate I I'm Rex rice I'm
the center for Pickens County Pickens
County's got the highest point in South
Carolina and that means we're closest to
God so they've asked me to come through
the prayer
I would tell you this you know my public
speaking I'm 30 years in politics and it
gets worse every year but I do a better
job of talking to God than I do other
people and I do a better job of
explaining my position to God because he
already knows it
other people so y'all just gonna have to
listen to my prayer but I do think you
need to do this I think everybody in
here needs to thank God for the things
he's given you and asking for what you
need and just do that yourself
with that will you bow your hands please
father thank you for this wonderful day
thank you for the opportunity to be here
father thank you for sending your son
Jesus Christ
he means so much to us he's he gave his
life and you sent him to deal with our
sins father we appreciate the men and
women of the Armed Forces
Memorial Day was this week all those men
and women that gave their lives
so that we could have freedoms just like
we're here today in this country father
be with our South Carolina
guard as they go to the Texas border and
defend our border thank you for all of
those men and women that are donating
their time to go down there father thank
you for the First Responders that we
have the law enforcement the EMS the
firefighters and father just help to
remember J Michael Mueller that was
killed this week down here in the Low
Country fighting a fire serving his
serving for us
father thank you for Ron and Casey and
for what they do and the fact that
you've encouraged them to run and be the
next president of the United States
father we we need them bad father will
you ask we we just ask for time and
prayer we ask for healing of people that
need their healing we ask for a peaceful
campaign we ask for victory whether it's
victory on Earth or Eternal Victory
father we need it father we pray for our
enemies because we have plenty of them
and father we just need to learn how to
come together we pray for wisdom and we
fight for knowledge and we pray pray for
courage so that we can run a campaign
that is peaceful to the people that we
serve father we just ask that we say the
right things at the right time and don't
say the wrong things at the wrong time
our country is divided and we need to
bring it back together and we can do
that
father just help us to respect those
people that may disagree with us and we
can disagree and respect each other
follow unite the United States of
America father be with not only this
team but all the teams that are
campaigning provide safe to them in
Jesus name we pray amen
thank you
at this time I'm going to bring
representative Micah case Caskey up here
he's a former I say farmer my dad would
get all over my case if I said that my
dad is a marine he's actually in the
grave now but he would if I ever said
former Marine my dad would get on my
case he is a marine so thank him for his
service
he's going to do the Flash
thank you Senator ladies and gentlemen
so glad you're here uh you know they say
in South Carolina there is more
patriotism in this state per square
incident anywhere else in the country
and I don't know of anything more true
it's a pleasure to be here uh before
laughs
I didn't want to be like President Biden
and Paul
I had to watch my steps
thank everybody for being here today
um and I'm like senator Rice
um
I don't speak a whole lot but I try to
do the right things and say the right
things to make people feel good and let
you know how I feel I'm Bill Hickson uh
I'm in the insurance real estate
business in North Augusta I'm a small
businessman
but I also serve in the South Carolina
House of Representatives I'm the new
chairman of house Ag and natural
resources and environmental committee
but it's my honor today to be here
from it is my honor to be here with you
today to hear from someone ready to
bring our country back to having Law and
Order again
as you may know I supported a candidate
for president a few years ago
mainly known to folks now is he needs to
talk less and listen more
when he became the president
um I was so excited but frankly right
now I've lost my my I've lost my
excitement
for many of the reasons and really I
mean so many reasons I want to be here
today to let you know that we can today
make a clean break with the past and
focus on much brighter future than is
waiting on us today but we need to put
Governor DeSantis in the White House and
he'd be our next 47th president of the
United States
no one was we are knowing where we are
as a nation I know our next president
needs to be Governor Ron DeSantis he's
proven himself as governor of Florida
he's a man who has worked hard to get
his education and a law degree with
honors
he is a distinguished he distinguishes
himself with a great military service to
our country he stared terrorists hatred
for America and to face it with
Guantanamo Bay and never blinked
he worked with the Navy SEAL Team One at
a forward face
he knows government has to be
accountable to the people at all times
Rhonda Sanderson always takes the lead
and is known as a world leader by he
being by him being governor of Florida
and look what he did during the covert
price crisis he hit that state going he
used good Common Sense Florida was open
24 hours a day 365 days a year and I
think that's a wonderful accomplishment
the governor's wife Casey graduated from
the College of Charleston that's right
right here in South Carolina
welcome back to South Carolina Miss
first lady
um Casey's parents live in Aiken County
and I think they're here today and I
would like to meet them in Aiken County
as part of my house district so I would
sure love to meet you
um she's not just a neighbor she's our
friend
so when Governor when you become the
next president of the United States we
welcome you back to South Carolina to
visit your family here
I know y'all are tired of him what I
have to say so he the governor is a man
that understands how to make government
for the people and not over the people
a man that means what he says so if you
would give us a great Palmetto State
welcome to Governor the Santa and his
wife Casey
foreign
ER
[Applause]
are you ready to bring to begin our
Great American comeback by sending Joe
Biden back to his basement in Delaware
spends a lot of time on vacation as it
is we might as well make it permanent
and I'm happy to oblige in that
we're excited to be here we're going to
be able to hear from my wife the great
first lady of Florida we'll have a
little chat in a few minutes but I'm
just going to make a couple opening
remarks look I think one thing that you
can know about me is that when I tell
you I'm going to do something I don't
just say that because I think that may
be what you want to hear then get into
office and forget all the promises I
made if I tell you I'm gonna do
something I'm going to do it and that's
just
[Applause]
and I think we've seen that with what we
were able to do in the State of Florida
we in Florida chose facts over fear we
chose education over indoctrination we
chose Law and Order over rioting and
disorder we held the line when Freedom
itself was hanging in the balance I
refused to let the State of Florida
descend into some type of faucian
dystopia where people's livelihoods were
destroyed and their freedoms were
curtailed no we protected people's
rights we protected people's jobs we
protected people's businesses we
protected our kids right to be in school
in person in short we chose Freedom over
faucism
[Applause]
and the thing about it is when you get
into a position as a governor president
an executive position yes you got to be
right on policy I mean we see Biden
fumbling policy in the country's going
in the wrong direction but being right
on policy is necessary but it's not
enough you also got to be a leader and
you've got to be willing to exercise
leadership in those critical moments and
so for us uh when we decided we're going
to chart our own course during covid we
were bucking fauci the bureaucracy the
media the left even a lot of Republicans
uh to chart our own course I was taking
a lot of incoming from that uh probably
more incoming than any Governor has ever
taken and I was getting hammered every
day and my even some of my supporters
would call me and they'd say Hey you may
need to reverse course here like you're
getting killed you're not going to be
long for this world politically if you
keep I know you think you're doing the
right thing but man you know think about
uh saving yourself here and you know a
leader
can't let whatever short-term political
calculations there are Trump what is
right for the people that he represents
you've got to be willing to go out there
and you've got to be willing to stand
your ground in the face of intense
opposition and criticism even if you
have to stand all alone that's what
you're called upon to do so I resolved
I'm gonna care more about protecting the
jobs of the people I represent than I am
about saving my own job I don't know
what will happen politically who cares
do what's right
and you know at the end of the day
leadership is not about entertainment
it's not about brand building it's not
about virtue signaling leadership is
about producing results for the people
that you represent and if you look at
Florida we've produced results across
the board I mean we're the fastest
growing state in the country you know
people tend to go places that are well
governed and they leave spaces that are
poorly governed is it any is it just a
coincidence that they're fleeing
California and New York and Illinois of
course not because they're poorly
governed States we're number one for net
in migration number one now by U.S news
and world report for Education number
one for Education Freedom number one for
Parental involvement in education
[Applause]
prime rate is at a 50-year low we have
no state income tax you all should try
it sometime it works out very well for
us
and we have the second lowest debt per
capita ratio of all 50 states the
federal government should try that
sometime it's much better
we've accomplished a lot because we lean
in on issues you know a lot of people
you get into office every decision you
make some people like it and some people
don't so a lot of elected officials they
say well I'm just not going to try to
make any decisions I'm not going to get
into issues unless it absolutely comes
on my desk and I have to make a decision
but that's not leadership and so we go
on offense we make sure that we're doing
everything we can to protect the
Vitality of the state and the freedom of
our citizens so just in the last few
years we've been able to do a lot and
here's just the sampling State of
Florida we have signed legislation
Banning the purchase of land by the
Chinese Communist party and its
affiliate
we have signed legislation kneecapping
ESG in the State of Florida no ESG in
the pensions
no woke banking discriminating against
conservatives no social credit scores in
the State of Florida we have enacted the
heartbeat Bill the strongest pro-life
Protections in modern Florida history
[Applause]
when we had hurricane Ian hit our state
last September it was almost a category
five and it initially hit in Southwest
Florida did a lot of damage but one of
the things it did it actually knocked
out a bridge going from the mainland to
Pine Island and it severed the causeway
going from the mainland to the Sanibel
Island in three different places and
these were not State bridges that were
under our control they were local the
local residents were being told you
better get off those islands it's going
to be six months before you can traffic
will be restored so they came to me and
they asked for help now this is another
thing like some people get in if it's
not their responsibility they don't want
to do it because if you get involved and
something goes wrong then you get blamed
so people get worried about it but I'm
like of course I'm going to help them so
I was like all right I'll help we'll
take it over what do we need to do so I
got my guys together I said listen uh no
bureaucracy no red tape and no excuses I
want this stuff done and we don't have
six months to do it so we took over the
job for the Pine Island Island Bridge
instead of taking six months we reopened
the bridge in three days and then in
Sanibel
took us another two weeks after that
and incidentally those guys that did
that building I've told Joe Biden I will
send them to the southern border to
build the border wall I'll do it just
let me know
but what it shows is there's always
going to be ways you can say you can't
do something they'll always be easy
excuses that you can proffer uh my view
is just find a way to get things done
and so we were able to do that on the
bridges and on so many other things
we've also enacted the biggest tax
relief in Florida history 2.7 billion
dollars including permanent elimination
of sales tax on all baby items cribs
strollers diapers wipes clothes you name
it you raise babies tax free in the
state of Florida
[Applause]
now my wife and I we have a six or five
and a three-year-old now when we first
became Governor it was two in nine
months we even have our third yet so
after I signed the the tax relief for
the baby eye that included the baby
items relief my wife said why didn't you
do this in 2019 we would have saved a
lot on diapers but you know we didn't
have bite inflation back in 2019 so it's
uh we're doing what we can to help we've
also enacted Universal school choice in
the State of Florida so parents can
decide where they send their kids
when I became Governor Florida had
probably the most liberal state supreme
court in the entire country I've now
appointed seven conservative justices
and we now have the most conservative
Supreme Court in the country
[Applause]
we've supported Second Amendment
freedoms by enacting constitutional
carry legislation
[Applause]
we are a Law and Order State and have
enacted policies to be tough on crime
making sure they have to post bail
before they get let out making sure
fentanyl dealers go to jail for a long
time and we have also authorized the
death penalty for pedophiles in the
state of Florida
and
and we support the police in Florida we
support law enforcement we're not going
to defund the police we're not going to
attack law enforcement
and in fact the last three years Florida
has done one thousand dollar bonuses for
every single police officer and
firefighter in the entire State of
Florida we're a big state that's a lot
of folks
in Florida we've recognized the Menace
posed by left-wing prosecutors who get
elected usually with big campaign
contributions from people like George
Soros and they get into office and they
decide they're going to let the
criminals get off the hook they won't
prosecute many laws that we really need
Prosecuting in order to keep order in
society and Chaos starts to reign
supreme the areas get hollowed out
people actually move from these cities
because of how bad things get well in
Florida when we had one of those
prosecutors say that he wasn't going to
enforce laws he didn't like in our state
I removed him from his post he is gone
[Applause]
we're cracking down on illegal
immigration in the State of Florida we
have banned Sanctuary cities
we're cracking down on human smuggling
we've sent National Guard to the border
to help with what's going on down there
and we even sent illegal aliens to
beautiful Martha's Vineyard
we've signed legislation protecting
Floridians from the imposition of a
central bank digital currency you don't
know what they're trying to do with that
read up on it we're not going to let it
happen in Florida and as President we
won't let it happen in the United States
but they want more control over what
you're doing
we are the first state in the country to
fully eliminate so-called Dei from our
Public University system
they say it's diversity equity and
inclusion but in reality it's ideology
and it's an agenda that they're trying
to shove down the throats of students
and even faculty Dei as it's actually
practice is actually better
characterized as discrimination
exclusion and indoctrination and that
has no place in our public universities
or public institutions
we've banned ballot harvesting in the
State of Florida and Zucker bucks in the
State of Florida and we have good strong
transparent elections we've also
protected Floridians against Biden's
attempt to impose the World Health
Organization lockdown treaty on America
we're not going to let that happen we're
pushing back
we govern ourselves we're not governed
by The Who we've also enacted
protections for medical Freedom no
vaccine passports no coveted shot
mandates mnra mandates emergency use
mandates no gain of function research in
Florida we actually did that
of all the things that we've done one of
the things I'm most proud of is what
we've been able to do with education
because I see that issue not just
through the lens of a governor but also
through the lens of a dad of a six a
five and a three-year-old and we believe
the purpose of our schools is not
ideological indoctrination indeed that's
not an appropriate use ever of schools
to be able to do we believe that parents
have a fundamental right to direct the
education and upbringing of their
children the school systems are
important but they're there to support
the community they're not there to
supersede the rights of parents and what
they think is appropriate and so we've
enacted protections for parents such as
curriculum transparency so that they
have a right to know what books are
being used and what curriculum is being
taught to their kids and unfortunately
there's bad stuff that's getting into
the schools there's pornography that's
getting in schools so the parents have
had to blow the whistle in Florida
they've had to they've had to yeah well
thank you thank you
um
[Applause]
[Music]
We're Not Gonna Let You impose an agenda
on our kids we're gonna stand up for our
kids we're gonna make sure to do it
right that's what we're gonna do yeah
those people like that in Florida are
the people we beat every single day on
policy we do not let them win
we win all these battles we're not
letting them indoctrinate our kids
not on our watch
and so the parents have found this stuff
and so then they'll go and they'll blow
the whistle and the media will say oh
that's a book ban if you remove an
appropriate material from a library
somehow it's a book band which is just
not true because in whatever's in a
kid's classroom you make decisions you
have one book about George Washington
there's a hundred others you could have
you're not Banning the other hundred
just because they're not in that Library
so you have to make decisions about
what's appropriate it's not appropriate
to have this pornographic material in
there and so we actually did a press
conference to highlight this and we
called it exposing the book ban hoax
because it is a hoax but before I said
anything before the parents came up we
just played the video that had the
images that the parents were objecting
to
the local news feed the local news
stations had to cut their broadcast
because they said it was too graphic to
air well if it's too graphic for the six
o'clock news how is it okay for a 10
year old school child
thank you
we have eliminated critical race theory
in our K-12 schools not teaching kids to
hate this country or to hate each other
with your tax dollars we're supporting
Civics education teaching kids about the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights
teaching them about what it means to be
an American because all of them no
matter what they do in their life are
all going to be citizens of our Republic
and we need to give them a proper
Foundation of why America is what it is
and what are our founding principles and
so we're doing that in Florida and we're
proud of it we've also drawn a line to
say it's inappropriate for a teacher to
tell a second grader that they may have
been born in the wrong body or that
their gender is a choice
no gender ideology in the schools
and when we did that the parents in
Florida were thrilled because you know
they just want the basics they want uh
they don't want the schools off kilter
with all this and so the parents liked
it now the left did not like it the
media did not like it and we had a
little company in Central Florida you
may have heard of that also didn't like
it you know named Disney but you know
Disney's view is that it's appropriate
to be teaching a kindergartner that
somehow they can change their gender uh
that's totally unacceptable uh to be
going on in schools and so
[Applause]
you know and unfortunately there have
been videos that come out about Disney
where some of their executives are
talking about you know it's their agenda
uh to put sexuality in the young kids
programming uh which as a parent I don't
think is appropriate and I don't think
it's right so they've gone in that
direction and they're opposed they were
posing us on parents rights a lot of
people in Florida say hey man they're
the 800 pound gorilla they get
everything that they want there's no way
you're going to be able to get this done
if Disney is opposing you you're gonna
have to back down well here I stand we
Evan back down one inch we do what's
right
and you know even some of these
Republicans now are taking Disney side
saying that somehow I was wrong you know
to do what we did but let me just say
very clearly we stand for the protection
of our children we will fight anybody
seeking to Rob them of their innocence
and on those principles there will be no
compromise
[Applause]
it's also wrong to have a swimmer
competing on the men's team for three
years and then switch to the women's
team and then be declared the Women's
National Champion
that is not acceptable for uh the
opportunities for our girls and our
women athletes like I have two daughters
my wife and I are sensitive we want our
girls if they so choose to compete with
fairness and integrity uh we're actually
supported in our campaign by a very
brave young swimmer named Riley Gaines
have you heard of Riley
and so in Florida we protect women's
sports part of it is to make sure the
girls have the opportunity but part of
it is just you know we have to be more
to the truth in this country and when
you go three years on the men's team
switch to the women's and they say
you're the Women's Champion we know
that's not true and we've gotta we've
got to be clear about that
and it's sad that we even had to do this
in Florida and I think you guys have
done it here other states have had to do
it but it's wrong to have a physician
performing sex change operations on
minors and yet you see that happening
so in Florida it's very clear we think
that that is mutilation we think that
that is wrong and if you do that as a
physician you're not only losing your
medical license you're going to jail as
a result
so I think what Florida shows is that
you know you can take all these
principles and beliefs and values that
we hold you can actually win big
victories and Institute that as policy
and then you see the state is doing
better than ever uh and politically I
got elected by 32 000 votes in 2018 this
we were like an evenly divided State
people told me hey trim your sales when
you get in as Governor Don't Rock the
Boat because if you do you could end up
capsizing it in favor of the the
Democrats of course I rejected that
advice I said I'm going to lead boldly
and that's what we did but fast forward
four years after that we didn't win by
32 000 votes we won by over 1.5 million
votes that was the largest Republican
landslide in Florida history in a
governor's race
you know we want independence by 18
points we want Hispanics with over 60
percent we even had like obviously we do
very well in Rural and we did very well
in Suburban but even in urban areas like
Miami-Dade County 2.8 million people uh
our largest county by far Hillary
Clinton had won that County by 30
percent in 2016 we not only wanted we
wanted by double digits in Miami-Dade
County that's winning
[Applause]
and here's the thing these elections are
team efforts it's not just about you you
have a responsibility to help the people
up and down the ballot and that's
exactly what we did in Florida we now
have super majorities in our Florida
legislature we helped elect four
additional Republicans to the U.S
Congress and we probably wouldn't have
the majority if not for that and we even
elected 29 additional conservative
school board members throughout the
State of Florida and for the first time
since I guess reconstruction uh there is
not a single solitary Democrat elected
to Statewide office in the Sunshine
State that's what you call winning
[Applause]
Florida also shows that when we say
something we mean it uh when we say we
do it we'll follow through so I can
pledge to this as president I'm going to
be a very energetic executive we are
going to go on offense uh we are going
to start from day one and we are never
going to look back we are going to
reverse Biden's disastrous economic
policies that are making it more
difficult for people to make ends meet
[Applause]
we're gonna stop spending this country
into Oblivion with the spending and debt
and printing money uh this debt deal
that they just taught that they're
talking about we were going bankrupt
before that debt deal and we are still
going bankrupt after that debt deal
they're given Biden four trillion
dollars in additional debt through the
end of his presidency they're also
keeping these inflated levels of
spending and even the 87 000 IRS agents
they're getting rid of like two percent
of those uh which is totally inadequate
in Florida we run budget surpluses our
debt is 17 billion dollars but our
economy is 1.2 trillion dollars if you
compare that to the federal government
our national debt is much higher than
our overall size of our American economy
and so we need to bring some fiscal
sanity to Washington we will do that we
also need to unleash American energy
production and be energy independent
thank you
we also have to focus the economy on
small businesses not these big massive
corporations during covid the biggest
businesses got bigger and they did
better Amazon all these things meanwhile
if you were in California or Illinois
New York you were a small business a lot
of them got put out of business by that
and so we have to have a small business
focused economy we have to have an
economy where hard work pays off because
it seems like under Biden people that do
the right thing end up having to pay the
bill for what the ruling class is doing
you know I was growing up I was a blue
collar kid my mom was a nurse my father
worked for Nielsen television ratings
back then to get the ratings they had to
install a device on the cable boxes and
so that's what they did his father was a
steel worker in Western Pennsylvania so
I was Blue Collar told you're not
entitled to anything you've got to earn
it and you've got to earn your way in
this world so I earned I work minimum
wage jobs as a teenager all the way way
through school for years and years to
help put my myself in a position to be
able to succeed and the only reason I
did that was because I believed in
America if you work hard if you make the
most of your god-given talents you're
going to be able to do well you're going
to be able to do good things and we're
losing that in this country and we need
to get that back
ours will be the look as Republican I've
been hearing about things like the
southern border for so long I've been
hearing complaints about it for so long
and yet it's worse than ever today so
our pledge is that our Administration
will be the administration that finally
brings the Border issue to a conclusion
we are going to shut the border down
we're going to build the border wall
we're gonna stop Mass migration and we
are going to hold the Mexican drug
cartels accountable for the Carnage that
they have Unleashed on this country and
we won't stop until we do that we will
also Usher in a reckoning for the
federal government's disastrous covid-19
policies everything from lockdowns and
school closures to mnra vax mandates the
whole shebang if nobody is held
accountable they're just going to repeat
this in the future so we're going to
bring accountability we're going to make
sure that history is clear about what
went wrong and the only way that we can
be sure it'll never happen again is to
hold people accountable because we can't
let this happen to our country ever
again
I believe that woke ideology represents
a war on Truth itself and so as
President we will wage a war on the woke
we will fight the woke in the schools we
will fight the woke and the corporations
we will fight the woke in the halls of
Congress we will never ever surrender to
the woke Mob We are going to leave woke
ideology in the Dustbin of History where
it belongs
on day one we're going to take Swift
action to restore the glory of the U.S
military and as somebody who was a
veteran you know I I'm working on these
jobs getting education all this stuff
you know I fortunately I had an
opportunity to make a lot of money uh
but I decided this is after 9 11 and
people was all volunteer people were
stepping up I was like you know as an
American I've got to do my part however
small I've got to do so we volunteered
to join the Navy uh we ended up serving
in the Navy uh you know we did a bunch
of different duties including a tour in
Iraq with Navy Seals as they had
mentioned and um you know even though I
could have made a lot more money I look
back and you know the satisfaction you
get from being able to wear the cloth of
your country to be able to serve
alongside fellow Patriots and to be a
part of a mission uh that's bigger than
yourself well that's something that
money just can't buy and so I appreciate
those who wear the uniform I thank
everybody here who has served and I
thank all of our veterans who have
served but I think what's happened now
and I have veterans coming up to me is
telling me they would not recommend
their kids or grandkids join the
military because of the wokeness because
of what they did to harass people on the
covet vaccess for all these different
reasons they're driving Warriors away
recruiting is in the basement when I was
in Fallujah Iraq you still had people
that were showing up to Paris Island in
South Carolina to join the Marine Corps
because they believed in the mission in
the country and they believed in the
service and now it's like there it's
hard to find people to want to do it at
that level and these people knew they
were going to get sent to Iraq so we
need to restore morale and I think you
restore morale by taking all the
politicized policies that Biden has
instituted you rip them out on day one
and say we're going to Mission first
we're going to treat people based on
Merit we are not going to be playing the
woke Olympics in the United States
military and so we will get that done
we will also take action to restore our
constitutional system founding fathers
devised three branches of government
executive legislative judicial they did
not devise a fourth branch of government
an administrative State a massive
bureaucracy that is unaccountable uh to
the average American right now most of
the major issues that affect our economy
and Society are not decided by your
elected representatives they're
instituted by nameless faceless
bureaucrats who you will never have the
ability to vote out of office you should
not have social or economic
transformation without representation
and of course as power has accumulated
that power has become sharp it's become
weaponized against people that don't
share the ruling classes values and
worldview I mean if Hunter were a
republican he would have been in jail by
now and we all know that's true
so we're gonna go about it day one
understanding this is a momentous
undertaking day one well you know day
one with me you'll have a new FBI
director in place which is uh important
but day one this requires the president
to be disciplined it requires the
president to be focused you can't get
lost in distractions because this is a
daily thing uh where you have people who
have a lot of power and they are not
going to give that power up willingly so
this is a tough fight but it's a fight
that we're gonna get done and don't let
anyone tell you oh I'll get rid of all
this on day one or I'll finish it in six
months or all that stuff this is a big
big issue and it's going to require
somebody that's very disciplined over a
very extended period of time and I
pledge to you I'll be that guy and part
of the reason we'll be able to do it
part of the reason we're going to be
able to do it is because I have the
humility to know that look I may be the
elected official I may ultimately have
to call the shots put forth the vision
and all that's very important but none
of that amounts to anything if you don't
have people surrounding you who believe
in that Vision who are going to work in
the administration and Implement that at
the ground level if you have a bunch of
people in your Administration who are
going to sabotage the agenda then what
good are you doing uh in the first place
and so we're gonna ask and I realize you
can't just recycle the same people from
Washington D.C we need people from
outside of DC you know we need people
from South Carolina
Florida and Texas and everywhere
and I'm going to ask people I'm going to
say look we need good quality people to
serve in this adminant because there's
thousands of positions that we need good
people to fill and you may need to pick
up your family for two years four years
six years eight years move to Washington
DC uh and serve in the administration
because you know
the bureaucracy in DC has imposed its
will on us for long enough it's about
time we the people impose our will on it
and that's exactly what we're going to
do
but here and we're gonna we're gonna
have a bunch of other good stuff that
will be uh love to talk about here in
South Carolina and elsewhere over the
many next many months but here's the
thing you can't get any of this done if
you don't win
there's no substitute for victory and we
have to dispense with the culture of
losing that has enveloped our party in
recent years you're not going to get a
mulligan on this 2024 election and
understand the Dems are Playing for
Keeps if they sweep into power in 2024
they are going to try to pack the U.S
Supreme Court they're going to try to
abolish the Electoral College they're
going to try to make Washington DC a
state and they are going to eliminate
voter ID laws in every corner of this
country and mandate ballot harvesting be
allowed in every corner of this country
that will be an attempt to lock
themselves in power for a generation and
if they're able to do that the damage is
going to be irreparable and so our
freedom is on the line President Reagan
used to say Freedom's one generation
away from Extinction it's not passed
along in the bloodstream I used to think
that was an exaggeration but after
living through the last four years five
years with covet and everything else
that's gone on I I don't see how you
cannot recognize that our freedom is
freedom is fragile and it really falls
upon us to do all we can to preserve it
and we have to do it for our own sake
our kids our grandkids sake we also have
to do it because we owe a debt of
gratitude for those who have sacrificed
for us so that we can be free people and
I'm reminded of that uh coming off this
Memorial Day weekend I used to take
flights up to Washington DC and there
was one particular route the plane could
take going into Reagan Airport that took
you flush parallel to the National Mall
and if you looked out the left side of
the plane you would see these beautiful
views of the Lincoln Memorial the
reflecting pool the Washington Monument
all these other monuments and then up on
the on the hill the beautiful U.S
Capitol building and you feel a sense of
Pride because I think those monuments
and buildings are symbolic about what
America represents but after doing that
trip a few times I realized the best
monuments were not out the left side of
the plane because if you looked out the
right side of the plane you looked over
the Potomac River you saw monuments that
were very small non-descript but they
were orderly arranged over Rolling Hills
in a place called Arlington National
Cemetery and it occurred to me that you
could have the best Declaration of
Independence in the world you could have
the best constitution in the world you
could have the best political leaders in
the world like George Washington himself
but if you don't have people that are
willing to stand up put on a uniform
risk their lives and indeed give their
lives
so that we can be free well those
principles aren't going to amount to
very much in the end and so I think we
owe it to them and the people that have
that have made great sacrifices on our
behalf to make sure that we're not
fumbling this football on the one yard
line uh and squandering our freedoms and
so we're not asked to make the same type
of sacrifices they made not even close
but we are called upon to be responsible
stewards of this great American
experiment we're required to carry on
the torch of what George Washington
called The Sacred fire of Liberty we're
required to stand firm for the truth and
we're required to remain Resolute in
defense of these enduring American
principles and my pledge to you is this
is that if you nominate me as our
candidate for this election on January
20th 2025 at High Noon you can set your
clock because on the west side of the
Capitol I'm going to have this left hand
on that Bible I'm going to have this
right hand in the air and I'll be taking
the oath of office as the 47th president
of these United States no excuses we
will get it done we'll make it happen
I'm going to bring the first lady up
here now
attack a little bit
a little bit less you guys
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much can I say something
real quick how excited are you to make
him the next president of the United
States
so uh first lady here first of all uh
obviously a great wife and mother but
she's done a tremendous amount of
service for the people of Florida she's
not I mean she's not compensated she
just does it because she wants to help
people and so you know we'll talk a
little bit about some of the stuff that
we've got going on in our household but
before I do that I wanted to give her an
opportunity to talk about some of the
initiatives that she has done because I
think this is a model for the rest of
the nation and I think when you talk
about what we believe as Republicans or
conservatives you know we ultimately
understand you know government's not the
solution to these problems and
government has a role but it needs to be
a proper role and she's understood that
better than ever and has had some great
success so take it away well thank you
first of all it's uh it's very humbling
and it's a privilege to be back in my
home state of South Carolina
so College of Charleston not going to
tell you what year because it's getting
a long a long time ago parents were in
Mount Pleasant by the way my sister and
my brother-in-law were C-17 Pilots based
in North Charleston for a while too so
it's really is home for a lot of us but
I appreciate what the governor was
saying because you know we're both of
the mind when much is given much is
expected and when he was elected I
looked at the opportunity that I had
before me not as it was about me it was
about the position of first lady when
you have that platform to be able to do
something what do you do so I was very
fortunate I went around and I traveled
around the State of Florida which by the
way was lovely there's a lot of great
places in the State of Florida going
down to the Keys and whatnot but I had a
chance to talk to folks particularly in
the Child Welfare sphere because that
really is where my heart is with single
moms and children in the foster care and
adoptive systems and also moms who are
pregnant battling substance abuse and
children aging out of the foster care
system and I wanted to have a better
understanding of what some of the key
stakeholders were saying on the ground
and how things operated one thing thing
I learned very quickly was that there
are a lot of great people on the ground
exterior of government who are doing
great things but they were all siled so
you guys can probably understand this
you had the faith-based community doing
wonderful things but they were over here
you had the private sector here you had
the non-profits you had the state
government but then there was oftentimes
very little communication and
collaboration on the best interests of
people in need so we decided we were
going to change that a little bit so
what we did in the department of
children and families and that is the
agency within the state government that
oversees the Child Welfare sphere we
decided to launch an initiative called
hope Florida so what is that basically
we have hope Navigators Navigators are
folks so when you have a single mom who
is in need of help instead of just
giving them a TANF Grant recipient or
money or government assistance and
saying you know I'll see you in six
months I hope it goes well for you what
they do is they hold the hand of that
individual and look exterior of
government so they look at all of the
non-profits available at the community
to meet her needs in the beginning but
what's amazing is that if they find that
there aren't any non-profits that are
servicing the needs of that single mom
we're one of the first states in the
nation to tap into the faith-based
community in a really meaningful way we
utilize a technology called care portal
care portal is something that our
Navigators use so let's say the single
mom she's having a hard time putting
food on the table she needs bunk beds
and mattresses and just needs overall
help we literally input that into a
system that goes out to our
participating faith-based communities in
the form of an electronic alert via an
email or an app they see that in real
time and they say yep you know what I
can actually do that we can get a bunk
bed together yeah we can get our team
and our congregation to cook a
home-cooked meal and they can literally
deliver that to her front doorstep so
now what has happened in this
philosophical change about the way we
approach government government is a
communicator and a collaborator and then
they get out of the way and what we find
is those inputs going into the care
portal system are used usually done only
once and you find well certainly that
Mom has more needs than just that but
what has happened is a communication and
a collaboration has now happened between
the good people who are already doing
wonderful things on the ground and some
people that they never knew were in need
of services like that single mom since
we've started this and there's a lot of
layers to it we've been able to help
transition off 5300 people off of
government assistance or partially off
of government assistance on a pathway to
economic self-sufficiency and these are
single moms when I see what we do to
bring the private sector involved so if
they are in need of a job and they say
Hey listen we can't work a nine to three
I would love to but but you know I want
to pick my a nine to five rather I'd
rather work nine to three because I want
to pick up my children from school I
want to be there to help them with their
homework so what we do is we ask the
private sector we say oh Walgreens will
you partner with us and help employ the
single Mountain they say yes well
employer 9-3 or whatever it might be to
be able to support her so she can
support her kids another great thing
that he's done is we tap into this
initiative is his Fatherhood Initiative
so he has done about 70 million dollars
reoccurring funds to help support
children in need of mentorship for these
single moms so when they're out working
we provide opportunities through our
collaborators to get mentorship Big
Brothers Big Sisters he's done a lot
with Tony junji because we find the
single greatest thing that you can do is
to provide these kids a mentor if you
show them value and worth and show them
that they are capable of whatever they
put their mind to they will succeed and
so we're facilitating these Opera
opportunities for these kids and so
we've really packed piped out a pathway
for a lot of folks but this whole
philosophical change to government what
we've done in the Child Welfare sphere
really doesn't end there we've taken it
to Veterans Affairs meaning how great
would it be for the faith-based
communities to know that you have a
veteran down the street they get a care
portal alert saying hey can you cook him
a home-cooked meal because sure would be
nice if you can show up at his front
door and say thank you we facilitated
those connections and we're making a big
difference and we're doing it to a lot
of other agencies too so this is just a
different way I think that we just
approach government
yeah I know it's been really really good
so
so I see this this water bottle and it
reminds us reminds me of a story uh with
with Casey uh and me and our kids so
before we had kids uh I was a member of
Congress and we went to Israel on a trip
so they uh that you can bring your
spouse so she came and uh you know we
got to see a lot of stuff and so when we
were at the seat of Galilee she had an
empty bottle of water and she filled it
up uh with water and said we're gonna
use that water to baptize our kids when
we have kids and so we brought it back
and you know the good thing is you bring
that back from to Israel Israel like
that it's not like TSA like this is like
real security so they saw it they're
like yeah that's water no problem go
ahead get on the plane so we didn't have
an issue with anything like that
um so we brought it back our daughter
was our first daughter was born uh 2016
did the baptism used use some of the
water great our son was born in 2018 but
this was during the governor campaign
the first governor campaign all this and
we're like we don't have time to plan a
baptism right now let's just get through
the election and so we did that and we
decided you know our friends and family
are going to be in Tallahassee for the
governor inauguration anyway so why
don't we just do it then and so I
actually announced in our inauguration
speech we're dispensing with the
inaugural parade which I don't like the
Pomp and Circumstance anyways and so no
parade and I was like we're going to be
returning to the governor's residence
where we're going to baptize our son
with water that we brought back from the
Sea of Galilee and so we went uh we did
it it was great and there now the
problem is you know we had about half
the water left and we you know we just
left it there in this room in the
governor's residence we are not used to
having people pick up after us right
well they have staff that do that and so
all they saw was a half used bottle of
water so the next morning I asked Casey
I say uh where's that see a Galilee
water it's like I think it's back
downstairs and I went downstairs no
there was no more see a Galilee water so
it had been spilled out so I was in uh
Boca Raton like a week or two late later
we're doing an event and I came out and
because people have been asking how the
baptism went and I said listen we
because the circumstances beyond our
control we are now out of water from the
Sea of Galilee we don't necessarily have
an a bun in the oven right now but you
know you never know and so within 24
hours there were people in Israel
digging into the Sea of Galilee and they
sent me this mate this big jar filled
with water I had it on my desk in the
state capitol until our third child
Mamie was born in 2020 and we used that
water for her baptism later so
oh little Mimi little maybe who's three
years old now first baby born uh to a
sitting Governor more than 50 years she
is currently terrorizing the house as we
speak
um you know my voice has actually gotten
better I don't know if I sound a little
hoarse it's because you know we've been
doing a lot we had a great uh crowd
earlier today in Bluffton we've been
doing a lot of great talking meeting a
lot of great folks the day before we
were up in New Hampshire we did four
stops the day before that we did five
stops in Iowa but that is not why my
voice is hoarse it is worse because I
spent the day before that talking with a
three-year-old for probably three hours
as to why she cannot take permanent
markers and color on the dining room
table and this happens a lot because you
hear of all of the great things that the
governor is doing when he's signing
legislation with that comes Sharpie
markers right because he has to have a
lot of sharpies and so they wind up in
the house and no matter as much as I try
to move them away the kids always end up
finding them and I have realized you can
move furniture as much as you want to
try to hide it after a while you just
run out of real estate and you just got
to get paint on the walls but our kids
are are awesome I mean we could sit up
here and talk about our kids all day six
five and three loads of stories it is a
little bit of a challenge I will say
living in the governor's residence with
a small family first family in 50 years
to have a small family because it's a
little bit like living in a museum you
know it's like look with your eyes don't
touch with your hands and that's hard to
do day in and day out we have learned
though that in the beautiful dining room
that we have there there's like early
19th century French wallpaper it's
supposed to be what Ponce de Leon saw
when he landed in St Augustine it's
beautiful we've learned that the magic
erasers do indeed get crayon marks out
of the wallpaper so that is a victory
for us we've also learned that the nice
rugs that they have there that have been
there for a very long time and have a
storied history you can get slime out of
it if you move fast enough and I was
thinking on the way over here I don't
know because our daughter loves slime so
much and we were FaceTiming in the car
on the way over here I was thinking
about my epic slime fails that I've had
with her because they've happened
numerous times like for instance if your
kids ever want to do edible slime don't
ever do that that's not a good idea and
the other Whopper that I did too with
the Slime because that's Madison's thing
she's our oldest she's six uh was if
they they actually make slime that you
can take a bath and you can turn the
bath water into slime which is not
really the best thing to do especially
when you're living in the governor's
mansion so
um I have a list of things for anyone
out there that wants to know how to get
things out of things I got it I'm good
well when we when we first became went
into the governor's residence
um you know we had a two-year-old and a
nine month old and you know I was just
like you know are they going to make us
leave a security deposit here because
you know there's just a lot but I will
tell you there are some of these rugs
that people who have visited in like you
know the state dining room be oh my gosh
that's a great Persian rug like well I
don't know anything but it does make
sense because when we first moved in
they have a private living room and so
we're there our kids and then Within
like a month the staff just kind of
rolled up that rug and got it out of
there and I always wondered why and I
think as they knew it would basically be
leaving it out for Destruction and so
it's a silverware too I don't know about
that yeah oh yeah the silverware too
with the kids uh yeah it's okay sort of
Irreplaceable history I get it but I
think we um you know parents right now
are going through a lot because it's
hard to raise kids I mean you know you
have social media you have a lot of
people that have an agenda in terms of
what they want to inject in education
and all these things and so you know
we're living it uh we hear what you're
saying because uh it's something that
that we're grappling with as well and
and I just think that if we if we can as
a country you know give our kids uh
really good education and upbringing
then you know we're really missing the
boat and so this is just a fundamental
issue that we've got to get right we
were we've taken it head on in Florida
been able to get a lot of good things
done
um and we're going to continue to do
that but certainly as president
um you know this has been to be an issue
that we will be speaking out about a lot
because it's important
foreign
kids to be happy you want them to have a
good upbringing you want them to just be
left alone you don't want to have to
worry about turning on the TV and having
somebody else's agenda be shoved on them
why are they insisting that they're
putting sexualized content in front of
five-year-olds and four-year-olds let's
just leave them alone and so I would say
this in the State of Florida we did
something pretty special when the
governor was re-elected we called on all
of The Mamas and the grandmamas across
the great state to help come on board to
help him get reelected and we had a very
ambitious goal and a lot of people were
looking at us like oh you're not going
to be able to do that I said well just
wait and so we said we're going to sign
up one million moms and grandmoms to
come out to support everything that he
has done for Education standing up
against the wool keeping the schools
open and we didn't meet our goal of
signing up a million moms and grandmamas
we actually signed up 1.1 million moms
and grandmoms
because I'll tell you it's one thing
when your policies come after me it's
another thing when you come after my
children that's when the claws come out
or our grandkids
you know you saw a lot of parents
because when covet hit some of these
parents didn't have the ability to even
get their kids in school so they're
having to do virtual they're having to
do all this you know in Florida we
obviously you know believe that these
schools had to be open and so we forced
that issue and you know I used the
leverage I had to make sure that that
happened but that wasn't the case
everywhere but then I think they started
to see what was going on with some of
the curriculum and a lot of parents
became very very concerned then you saw
how some of the kids would be treated
like forcing them to wear masks for
eight hours a day that was not based in
science no one had ever said you put a
six-year-old kid first of all the
efficacy of some cloth mask
um aside you have to wear it right
anyways these six-year-old kids are not
it's it's dirty they put it in their
apartment it's just ridiculous so we
really leaned in on the parents rights
we fought our local school districts to
make sure that the kids didn't have to
wear masks and they fought us and we won
that fight you know all these things
like you know we'll do something they'll
find a liberal judge you try to stop and
we always end up winning but I mean this
is just um uh this is another one and so
you saw a lot of that and I think this
whole day
do I think parents look at it and they
just wonder there was never any question
when I was growing up about watching any
of these cartoons or movies it was fine
right and then now it's like I hear from
parents like I was there within 10
minutes something something happened and
um yeah that's just not the direction we
need to go we in Florida it's sad we had
to do this you know we had to hold
establishments accountable for allowing
miners to come in to like these sexually
explicit drag shows I mean it's like why
would you bring a 10 year old kid to
something like that so if they do it
they lose their liquor license and they
get fined and all this stuff so we're
we're doing what we need to do but there
is a concerted effort to kind of go
after the kids now I think in a way that
wasn't necessarily true when I was
growing up and so we recognized it and
we're fighting back against it yeah and
I would say the people are with us on
this despite what you might hear in
other places because that Coalition of
moms were not all Republicans there were
a lot of Independents and a lot of
Democrats that did not like what the
left was imposing upon their kids and
they wanted to stand up and fight back
you know and I think he talked about it
in his speech a little bit but I think
it's really important that everything
that Florida has led on you look at his
election when he was first elected in
2018 he won by 32 000 votes in a state
of 22 million people right and then you
fast forward leading on all of these
issues standing up for parents standing
up and defending the innocence of kids
and then he ends up winning by 1.5
million votes in a re-election and that
was a 20-point margin and so that shows
you that when you run and you do what
you know and your heart is right you
stand up for moms and listen I'll tell
you during covet it was particularly for
me it was tough watching a lot of these
moms we would go out on the road and I
would see Moms come up to him with tears
in their eyes because when the world was
going mad they were wondering am I going
to be able to put food on the table for
my family or my kids going to be in
school and what's going to happen to
their god-given opportunities I mean are
they going to force these masks on my
kid are they going to force an mRNA shot
on them to be able to go to school and
when he held the line in sense of their
Liberties their rights and their
freedoms and he didn't back down and he
was the voice that they needed but they
didn't have the opportunity to
articulate it themselves I could not be
more proud of everything that he did and
you look at the rest of the country and
the way they followed suit and I'm
forever grateful for him holding the
line
thank you
all right
well does anyone have any questions for
the first lady or for me is there
anything uh anything you anything else
we need to address
oh how we met okay good question that's
a story so uh I was a lieutenant Junior
grade in the Navy stationed in Naval
Station May 4th do we have any navy
veterans in the house here okay thank
you appreciate your mate
and I had not been down there very long
uh and then she was a a TV reporter in
Northeast Florida and you know I was I
played baseball all the way through
college and um but you know you know
that was over and so I needed to find
something to do so I started to try to
learn how to to play golf so I just I
went to a driving range one afternoon in
uh in Northeast Florida and so I'm
sitting there you know just hitting the
balls whatever next Bay in front of me
someone had left a bunch of balls there
and then in the next Bay in front of
that there was this beautiful young lady
hitting golf balls right by me and um
and so her back is to me and you know
I'm facing her and I keep see her
looking looking over her shelter and I'm
like she's checking me out I gotta go
talk to her
the truth is
she was looking to see if I was going to
grab those extra golf balls that's what
she wanted and so you know I ended up
basically I I ended up using those balls
to kind of approach her anyways and I
said you know would you like to split
these or whatever and we kind of just I
introduced myself we started talking and
then um you know this is like 2006. so
there were no smartphones back then and
so I said hey you want to go out and and
um after this and so she got I got in my
pickup truck she got in her car and I
was new to the area I didn't really know
where I was going and you didn't have a
map on your phone like you do now so I
just I didn't yet get her phone number
so she's following me and I'm like oh
gosh I gotta find a place because I
don't want to lose her and then so I'm
driving driving driving finally like a
mile or two down the road I found a Beef
O Brady's so we went there and hung out
and Beef O Brady's and uh and then I got
her phone number and then we started
dating um after that and kind the rest
is history yeah it's
just a Publix a chiropractic clinic and
like a veterinarian office and so I'm
like where you know like what and then I
saw the Beef O Brady's but it's so funny
because people people always say did you
ever think that you would be in this
position I'm like oh no way like he was
a cute guy in the Navy like we just met
on a driving range you know it's just so
funny uh that we wind up here and so the
honor well so
um
I saw some people had the book If you
read my book you would know this but um
it's just ironic given what's happened
in more recent years but we actually got
married at Walt Disney World if you can
believe it
now it wasn't my idea and full
disclosure and I didn't think of them as
I didn't even know woke wasn't even an
issue then or any of that but um she
came you know because my view on the
wedding was look it's your day you know
you you run with it like I'm low
maintenance if there's something that
really crossed the red line that I
wasn't comfortable with maybe I would I
would chime in but by and large you
should just do what you want so she came
to me one day she said hey what do you
think about uh if we did the mayor the
wedding at Disney and I'm like Disney I
didn't even know they did that I was
just thinking like what are you gonna do
like Cinderella's castle or something
like that turns out they gave a
beautiful wedding chapel
um and and they have they have
facilities for it but I told her I said
look I'll do it but I just want the
wedding to look traditional I don't want
Donald Duck in our wedding and that was
my only uh request and so you know we
ended up doing it and um you know it's
just funny because we're doing it we're
we're a newly married couple and then
fast forward what 10 12 15 years later
and this is like a source of contention
in the State of Florida where we're
having to stare them down you know part
of the issue with Disney that a lot of
times the Legacy Media misrepresents is
they had their own government in Central
Florida they controlled almost 60 years
and so the way it was they were given
this this government uh and it was they
were going to be able to build the park
without having to follow any rules
basically and get tax breaks but they
were going to build communities of world
residents so it ended up would have been
they wouldn't have governed it you know
one if they would have followed through
on that they didn't follow through on
that they just kept building more Parks
uh and so you have this situation where
it's a 40 square mile area where they
based the company was the government
effectively and that is not good
government but they were able to sustain
that through many decades because of how
powerful they were well when we had this
this issue you know we had to look at it
and say okay this is a company that's
now indulging the sexualization of
children that is not a company we can be
joined at the hip with they're free to
do business like Universal and Sea World
does and everybody else we our business
is booming in Florida we have one of the
best business climates in the world but
to put one company on a pedestal and
give them their own governing status
that didn't work for me so we ended
Disney self-governing status in the
State of Florida this is the right thing
do
they have to live under the same laws as
everybody else they have to pay their
fair share of taxes and they're
responsible for any debts that they had
racked up over these many many decades
and so we were able to get that done you
know they they sued us this is a total
bogus suit we're going to absolutely win
that
um and look there's a new sheriff in
town and that's the way it should be I
mean how is it fair to every other
person in business in Florida that they
have to live under different rules than
this one this one Corporation so um you
know we're we're proud that we took
action there and
but you know Florida also has Legoland
and Peppa Pig theme park and and Sea
World and Universal and all these things
yeah uh you know what I know it's
getting hot so one more funny story
because I always get this people are
saying are the kids going to come out
and join you and yes because you know it
is very hard and you get it parents and
grandkids it is so hard to leave them
they don't understand sometimes why
you're going and doing what you're doing
and of course we'll we'll tell them the
importance of standing up for Liberty
and freedom and why you need to be in
the arena and fight for what you believe
in but they're going to come out maybe
one at a time because when you have all
three that young it's a little bit of a
challenge you guys well know buckling
seat belts and that sort of thing is not
easy but I was just thinking about we
did take two of them when you did your
trade Mission uh when we went overseas
you were in Japan and South Korea and
then on to Israel and the United Kingdom
and that was in the span of a week we
were he was going over to try to do
business and lure you know folks to
attract to Florida the free state of
Florida and we brought our six and our
five-year-old with us which we never
really got on a schedule because how do
you right and so when we got back after
this literal whirlwind trip around the
world
um they were some of them were sleep
Madison was sleeping I was kind of
sleeping Mason our son just crashed I
mean he was exhausted on the day that we
got back but then all of a sudden he
decided what was it like eight nine
o'clock I forget what I was like
midnight like midnight he woke up and he
was up and he was hungry
well first of all going to bed we got
back that day at 3 A.M our oldest had
dance practice at 8 A.M our other two
had t-ball at 9 00 a.m then they had a
dance recital then a birthday party and
so we were running on fumes ourselves
but everyone else is getting ready to go
to bed Mason's up you know midnight and
he's like hungry wants dinner so I'm
like what am I supposed to do so I take
him through the drive-through at Raising
Cane's chicken fingers when you're going
through it that night at that time of
night in a college town it was like I
think college kids who had been drinking
and me and Mason going through the
drive-through at raising canes and it's
just funny because these are just the
things uh that we do as as parents but
um we're honored be here uh we asked for
your support
um you know I pledge to you we will get
the job done I'm sick of excuses I'm
sick of always trying to explain why
things couldn't get done we're gonna get
the job done in November of 2024 and
then come January of 2025 buckle your
seat belts because we will be Off to the
Races and we're gonna get all this done
thank you God bless
all right
goes with my business
he stands up for why he believes
[Music]
you can take